the other thing he did which was um
completely fearless is if you look at
that him on the espys
you know that
you've seen that footage of him on the
espys and
you know
people were so angry at the time because
he's going after these athletes and
there was this sense of like you can't
do this
and he took so much [ __ ] for that
and then you look at it now that's what
the espys has become
you know espy's now is is like a lot of
people doing jokes about
a rose a roast yeah but it it became
more that way
he just did that first
and at the time people were really upset
and at the time
um
you know
you feel like there's a lot of
in comedy
people
getting applause for being brave in one
way or another
but
oftentimes
what they're doing they know is going to
play well you know what i mean but when
he's but when he's doing it yeah he was
doing things that really were brave and
he paid the price for it yeah he took a
lot of heat
when uh he went out he took a lot of i
mean it cost him his job at sarnot live
yeah and he was
one of his bosses was friends with a
murderer
and he and so norm was going to alleged
okay
this is a show that follows the rule of
law
all right you can just plug in alleged
uh we can edit that i've seen no proof
andy yeah
but he was so and the word i get i mean
i'm assuming that it came down hey lay
off the oj stuff because norm would do
at the time like five oj jokes in a row
and to norm sensibility something
somebody saying hey the big boss wants
you to stop making jokes
about that murderer yeah norm is like
no
like if anything that you should not
back off of it's making jokes about a
murderer you know whatever he's doing
tough for you at that time well i
remember um
uh and i have it somewhere either i have
it or jeff ross has it but
um we gotta we got the word came down
you you can't book nor mcdonald anymore
and it came from the top and
from donnellmeyer and
um
you know donald meyer was the one that
you know
lauren suggested me for late night he
gave me the job and so i had a lot of
you know feelings of loyalty to don
ulmeyer uh because i i wouldn't be here
right now if it weren't for don sticking
with me so i owe him that so i wrote
a letter
to don that said
you know
i i got this directive
you've hired me to do the best show i
can do and this is my best guest
and so i need to do yeah what i i need
to do my job which is the best show i
can do
and um
[Music]
uh
i got the
i got the letter back
and written in the margins was just
something
i don't remember the exact but it was
something
like i'm you know i would expect i
expected better from you or something
like that it was it was basically
me being told
um do as you're told yeah but or i'm
really disappointed in your
lack of loyalty or something and i felt
at the time that's not no that's not a
lack of loyalty that is loyalty i've
gotta yeah
so um
it was
uh
you know
i always greedily
wanted more norm
and
you know i was upset you know this is in
a purely selfish way but
the number one fan recruit request i
think the this podcast now is only three
years old
the number one request
for a guest
by far ahead of everyone norm mcdonald
yeah and we tried for a long time to get
norm to come on the podcast
and couldn't get him to come on and i
you know started to get into my head
about it and think well is something
wrong is he upset with us and it's only
now that i'm realizing that he was ill
um it was hard to book him on the show
you know
it became paula
said that you know we try constantly and
he just
wasn't doing anything yeah we were all
scratching our heads
we were all wondering where he is and
and i know that fans
were thinking
well you know where is he and
uh we we were as confused as anybody and
of course now sadly you know we know
um
how much
difficulty he was having yeah
and and how long and how very sick how
long he's been second how very sick he
was but
um
[Music]
uh
yeah i go back to again like i'm i'm
like a dog with a bone
trying to figure out
um he's very uh
you know i'm just going to tell frank is
new to this so he keeps shuffling papers
right up against a microphone uh there
you go
that's okay frank he wants it to make
sure you can have it right here on the
table
he wants some people to know we're
reading from a script
he's got all these notes norm equals
funny like that's not gonna
that's not gonna help you i remember uh
you know i gave this shout out to jim
downey earlier jim downey and and and
norm were such a good team because
they both
have
a very high bar for comedy and a really
good ear and i think norm was the
perfect vehicle for
for um
jim's humor and vice versa so they were
just had a really copacetic relationship
but one of my favorite norm jokes of all
time was an oj joke
and the picture comes up and it's that
picture of johnny cochran
at the trial and o.j is seated next to
him and johnny cochran's holding up the
knit cap that was found at the scene
and forgive my bad normal impression but
it was kind of like uh
something along the lines of uh you know
uh rough uh difficult time today in the
o.j simpson trial uh johnny cochran uh
uh uh introduced the the uh knit hat
that was found at the uh scene of the of
the murders uh and he held it aloft and
showed the jury uh this the hat that had
been found uh
things got off the rails a little bit
when o.j simpson
uh interrupted him and said hey hey
careful with that
that's my lucky stabbin cap
and
i
remember
that joke came through the tv and
slapped me in the face it was so good
yeah yeah um and i love the whole light
and of course you know norm what he
would do
is
uh and i never saw him do he would tell
the joke
and then
he would stare you down yeah through the
television yeah like try that on for
size yeah
something no one else could get away
yeah and you would look like such an
[ __ ] yeah if anybody else did but you
know that's what that's my lucky
stabbing cap yeah and then you can just
see his eyes
on fire and that grin and he's gonna
hold it there and he knows he's gonna
lose his job yeah he's gonna lose his
job over this
funniest guy to ever be on that show in
you know and he's going to lose his job